- Good morning Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe.
I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all
the major problems of the world.
And today's message is make no excuses.
Over to you, Jon Taffer.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- As a consultant for 30 years,
I learned everything there
is to learn about success.
What you do to be successful.
Management, marketing, costs.
Everything in my whole life
was, this is what you do
to be successful, this is
what you do to be successful.
Now after 92 bar rescues,
I know more about failure
than any consultant I've ever met.
You didn't even have to
sell a drink to make money
last night did you?
Come here shake your,
give away his booze, and
leave with your money.
There's a walk to failure,
there's a talk to failure.
You can see it.
And I found, because I've been
exposed to so much failure.
'Cause remember as a
consultant, most people either
have money or some level of
success if they're calling you.
The people I go to in Bar Rescue
can't afford to buy me lunch.
I mean they are broke!
So, when I take a look at
the terrible situation that they're in
and the pressure that I'm
under to turn them around,
the fact of the matter is
the only chance that I have
of making them successful, is
by making them accountable.
So, in all of these rescues,
I've found a common
denominator of failure.
And it's excuses. So you wake
in the morning you're failing.
It's in the middle of the
recession eight years ago
so you blame it on the recession.
But even in the middle of the
recession somebody was making
money in your town right?
So that excuse is bull.
How about the excuse,
I'll blame the president,
blame Greece, the Euro is
affecting my income in New York.
You can blame everything
in the world, you can blame
the weather, the president,
the mayor, the city,
construction, traffic,
snow, terrible this, that.
But the fact of the matter is
you're failing because of you.
Because in the snow somebody
made money, in the cold
somebody made money.
In the heat.
So every excuse is bull.
You're failing because of you.
So if you wake up in the
morning and look in the mirror
and blame it on the president,
you've got no reason to change.
But if you wake up in the
morning and look in the mirror
and say "I am a failure"
you're not going to like it.
And now you have to change.
So I force them to own failure.
I will not allow them to
push it off on anything
but themselves.
And when you own your
failure, you won't like it
and then you'll own your success.
- Successful people don't make excuses.
Successful people don't complain.
If you look at whoever
you want to look up to,
look at the most successful
people in the world
in any industry, look at
the top and look at how much
they complain.
They don't complain.
When you complain, when
you blame something else,
when it's the governments
fault or interest rates fault
or the bad economy's fault,
or your partner who screwed
you over, or the customers who don't care.
As long as you can blame
somebody else right?
The education system, your
parents, your friends,
your upbringing, there's
always somebody else to blame
and when you blame somebody else,
when you're in that mindset,
then you never grow.
You're making things easy on yourself.
It allows you to coast.
It allows you to play life
super safe because it's
not your fault that you're
not more successful.
Of course it's not your fault,
that would be difficult.
That would be hard.
It's somebody else's fault
so you could just stay where
you are because people
are holding you back from
accomplishing the thing
you want to accomplish.
Where successful people
take responsibility
for where they are in life.
And they say, I don't
care about the government,
I don't care who's
president, I don't care about
regulations that you have
or things that you're
holding me back on.
I will still go out and get mine.
And of course there are other factors.
Of course the country
you come from matters.
Of course education you
had and the connections you
had growing up.
Of course it matters.
But so what?
You have to play the
hand that you were dealt.
You have these cards.
You have to play those cards
and you can have success.
One of the things I love looking at,
and this is why I do
all of these profiles,
the successful, famous entrepreneurs.
There is always somebody who
has done way more than you
have done with way fewer
resources than you already have.
So no matter what terrible
situation that you have,
and I'm empathetic.
Maybe you come from a broken home.
Maybe you have a really severe disability
that's physically holding
you back from doing
some of the things that you want to do.
Maybe there's a lot of pressure on you.
Maybe you have some disease.
Maybe you have zero money
in your bank account.
These are real pressures
and I'm empathetic to that.
But so what?
The longer you believe that
those things are going to hold
you where you are then they will.
There are people who
have worse conditions,
less money, are in worse
situations and they came out of it
and accomplished amazing
things because they believed
that they could.
And that somebody that looks
like you has gone on and
accomplished big things, then you can too.
And it only happens when
you accept responsibility
for where you are in life.
So I could look at my
YouTube channel and say
"The YouTube algorithm
changed, the YouTube algorithm
is all over the place now,
I can't figure it out.
Stupid YouTube for
changing their algorithm
and hurting my videos."
I'm pumped whenever the
YouTube algorithm changes.
I'm so excited because the
people who are ahead of me
and the people who are
getting all of the videos
and all the views?
The people who are complaining?
I love it.
Change it more cause I'm
going to figure it out.
I love the process of figuring it out.
Whenever there's chaos, I see opportunity.
And that's what entrepreneurs do.
The most important thing that
you need as an entrepreneur
is not resources, it's resourcefulness.
So no matter what is thrown at you,
and you're going to get
a lot thrown at you.
In your life you have already had a lot
of stuff thrown at you and guess what,
as an entrepreneur, you're
just going to get punched
in the face again.
It's going to get worse.
You're going to get more thrown at you.
It's going to be eating
more crap for years.
This is the life you signed
up for and on the other side
is amazingness.
So when you accept
responsibility for where you are.
When you realize that in every situation,
no matter how much outside
your control you think it is
there's always something
that you can do to make your
situation better.
When you accept that full
responsibility and stop
making excuses, that's
when life starts to change.
That's when your business
starts to explode.
And that's when you
start to see the impact
and financial wealth that you
want to create for yourself
start to happen.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
what has typically been the
biggest excuse that you've had?
The biggest complaint that
you've had that you've
told other people that
as of today is over.
Leave it in the comments below.
Super curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Tina.
Tina thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and making
that calligraphy art.
And your one word is love.
I really appreciate that
and I'm glad you're enjoying
the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
(typewriter clacking)
- I don't believe in excuses.
Because the thing about
it, when you make an excuse
the thing that you have
to realize about life,
somebody has it 10 times worse than you.
And you're making an excuse
because you're soft man.
(audience applauds)
I've never cheated myself.
Ever since I was seven
years old and everything
that I did, I took pride
in what I did and I firmly
believe the harder you work,
the harder it is to surrender.
You see a lot of people don't understand,
if you go through life
and you cheat yourself,
there is going to come a
time when inner certain
meets diversity and if you're
not who you are supposed to be
and adversity will always
introduce you into who
you really are.
And if you haven't been working that hard,
if you haven't been sacrificing.
If you haven't been emptying that bucket.
If you haven't been born an only,
then every aspect of your
life is going to crush you.
Is going to make you give up.
Is going to make you stop.
Is going to make you make excuses.
But if you work hard,
if you've got a certain
person in you that when
you hit adversity and you hit opposition,
and you want to make excuses.
And that person inside of
you is saying "Man you ain't
"built like that.
"You know you're better than that.
"You know you're not like that man."
You deal with it and you keep going
and you embrace it man.
That's what life's about.
That is how people get stronger.
People don't get stronger
by you making excuses.
People get stronger by when
you go through adversity
when you go through trial and tribulation
and you look at it and when
it hits you in the face
you back up a little bit
and it hits you again,
you back up a little
bit, and you step back up
and you say "If that's all
you got, you in trouble!"
- I was in Johannesburg a little while ago
and I went through the airport
and I went into the
men's room, or washroom
or bathroom, however you want to call it.
And so I walked into the
men's room and the first thing
I hear is "Welcome to my office."
And this was the janitor at
the Johannesburg men's room.
- That's funny.
- Who janitorized, or I'll make up a word,
cleaned the men's, the toilets,
like Mozart composed music.
- Mm-hmm.
- Now that man has no money.
That man probably has
very little education.
That man is judged by the world as having
an unimportant job.
- Right.
- And that man is a hero,
could be a hero to millions
of people.
Why, because he actually saw
himself as the ambassador
to South Africa.
And his passion was palpable.
And his visceral commitment
to doing work at the highest
level was like you don't
see even from the CEOs.
- Right.
- And all I'm saying is,
even the person with the broken heart,
the person who's down on their knees.
Whether they see it or
not, they have a choice
to rise above their circumstances.
And leadership and humanity
is a testament to the people
who have done it.
I mean you look at Mandela,
27 years in imprisonment.
When his son died, he
wasn't allowed to attend the
funeral of his own son.
He said that was one of the
great pains of his life.
And what did he do?
The victim looks at
something like that, torture,
and says "I am broken."
And they give up and they
close their heart, they close
their mind, they close their
creativity and they blame
the rest of their life
on what happened to them.
- Mm-hm.
- But Mandela, what he chose
to to do, was to use it as
an opportunity because actually,
the things that break
your heart, if you choose,
can open your heart.
Fear, the world says fear is bad.
Fear is only an opportunity
for bravery training.
And what he did was he used
those 27 years of torture
to open himself mentally,
physically, emotionally,
and spiritually to the point
where when he was released
and became the President of South Africa,
he invited his jailers
to sit in the front row
at his inauguration and he
was asked why and he said,
"Because if I don't,
I'd still be in prison."
And that's a long way
of saying but, you know,
we do make excuses
because we are very good
at self-deception.
Because if we actually had
to face the responsibility
of playing with our bigness in the world,
we'd have to let go of our
addiction to our excuses
and leave what's safe.
Am I making sense?
- No totally, no you're
totally making sense.
- You'd have to leave what's safe.
I mean we are addicted to crisis sometime.
It makes no sense.
We are addicted to pain.
- Mm-hmm.
- And we have to actually
leave the pain to go out
to the possibility of pleasure
and joy and greatness.
And believe it or not, that frightens us.
- Right.
- So we make these excuses
and then we blame people.
Oh Joe or Robin, I don't
like the way he looks.
He speaks differently but subconsciously,
as you're suggesting, those
are just our protective
mechanisms to avoid owning
the responsibility of our--
(whooshing)
- What do you feel
separates good athletes from
the best athletes?
- I think it comes back to what
I was saying earlier about,
I mean I think a lot of it is mental.
You know if you want to do
something, and you want it
that bad, you'll make sacrifices.
And you know growing up for me as a kid,
I made a lot of sacrifices
that I didn't see them
that they were a big deal
and I don't think of them as
being a big deal right now.
You know, there were Saturdays
or Fridays where, you know,
I'd give up going to a dance
or hang out with my friends
cause I had workout the next day.
But those things that I gave
up, you know, were things
that I wanted to, to
help me get to my goal.
And there were times where
I've been put in uncomfortable
situations but I've used my
mental power and my mental
strength to push through it.
I think that's how you can
look at any of the athletes
in the world.
I mean Tiger, that guy has
a busted knee and still
comes in and destroys
the rest of the field.
You know that's the thing.
It's like people don't make excuses.
Some of the best athletes
or the greatest athletes
in the world do things
when they're uncomfortable.
You know everybody can compete
when they're feeling good,
happy, excited, rested.
But it's the best people who
can overcome when they're
tired, sore, not in the great mind.
You know, not in the best mindset.
And I think mental power that
the greatest athletes have
can push all the pain aside.
You know like when I was
doing that Navy Seals thing
was it easy for me to do it, no.
Was it easy for me to
climb over a 45 foot wall
and look down?
Not at all and I'm afraid of heights.
But, you know, I said to
myself I'm going to do this
and no one's going to stop me.
And I think that's the
biggest thing is how strong
you can be mentally.
I think that really
shows who the person is.
So I think that's the one
thing that separates the good
from the greatest.